c'est comme ça chez vous jean paul
belmondo avec une belle pelouse bien
peiné des tulipes soir mais pas dans
votre maison du val de marne certains
comme ces arrivages habitat tout près
d'ici peu je peux venir en vélo en
studio et j'ai des bennes pelouse comme
ça aussi mais il n'ya pas que les coûts
non césar bien bien coupé oui mais c'est
à dire que moi j'ai pas du tout le goût
du jardinage ce lien les jardiniers qui
sait ça mais j'aime bien regarder scène
bien me mettre dans l'air ne vais pas le
bal bout de tondre le gazon je me
demande si cette réputation est bien
justifiait ce de ce que pour certains
vous êtes un mec un dur un costaud sous
entendu parler on a l'impression d'être
un garçon plutôt marrant sympathique
calme pas trop de problèmes rassurant
bien consciencieux bien gentil services
existants une réputation de dur de pas
par l'équipe que jouent ces actions
m'embête sur mare sur les pièces mois
d'efforts mais si personne ne vient me
chercher ce 3e n'est même quand j'étais
jeune et je me suis battu quand même
assez souvent mais si jamais comment ces
masses attend qu'on vienne s'écraser les
pieds si on les écrase passé en maison
qu'il avait prise avait un petit côté
majorité silencieuse on peut dire ça aux
majorités cyr à 16h c'est rien au choix
qu'est ce qui vous agace dans la vie par
exemple pas moins un rôle que vous
auriez eu envie de faire et puissance et
pain ça n'a pas plus bas ça m'est arrivé
je voulais quand je devais jouer la puce
à l'oreille pour pour des sombres
histoires ça s'est passé ce que je pense
que tu es né avancé quand on est acteur
et qu'on trouve pas drôle non je n'ai
pas mes dix ans quand j'étais jeune j'ai
eu ce problème c'est à dire d'aller
passer des auditions d'hier un thème
souvent des gens qui vous regardent et
c'est vraiment comme dans l'histoire
allez-y faites moi rire ça c'est
terrible ça ça ça va beaucoup parler
basket international tout les les pièces
où j'allais il fallait que je devais
lisent le texte devant chauffants des
types dans une salle cordiale me
trouvais pas bien un peu tu as raison
sans doute mais c'est pas agréable
j'ai l'esprit de revanche quand même
maintenant acquis peu non parce que les
prix vous en avez pas eu beaucoup aux
distributions j'étais un peu le dernier
de la classe en un petit pont ab oui
mais mais je crois que je suis le chat
des zags dernière je crois que suis
l'acteur tulle - de prix donc cinéma
parce que quand je te concerne bien
évidemment ce n'est n'est pas eu de prix
et de toute façon même ans après quand
je suis arrivé je n'ai jamais eu de près
nulle part je suis l'acteur son prix
assez parce que les producteurs vous
diront pas ce que diront bien cruz paris
je voulais vous dire que vous le dire
parce que yi de m e génération m'a dit
je vous avais le prix parce que
maintenant je voudrais bien voir un
président alors moins avoir le prix
citron et j'ai été battu de peu par marc
de 39 ans n'a lui non plus mais une fois
j'avais le on m'avait dit on est venu me
trouver ici d'ailleurs tourné à saint
maurice et aux médias vous avez une prix
orange
il faut venir le chercher à midi alors
j'ai dit non mais je peux pas parce que
ce travail car bomb alors on va le
donner un élan donné à l'autre alors là
si vous avez un prime donnée aux
problèmes
où et quand on reconnaît le vrai
belmondo est-ce que c'est sur l'écran ou
plutôt en profondeur mais je sache
cependant sur l'écran je vais souvent
les gens vous identifie à ce qu'on est
sur l'écran on imagine c'est moi j'ai
joué pas mal de dure 10 euros ou de
rigolo l'arbizon plutôt tendance quand
il voit dans la rue à me taper sur
l'épaule et rigoler avec moi mais
diantre si j'avais débuté par léon morin
prêtre par exemple et on aura prêté à
gros succès peut-être l'attitude des
gens auraient échangé mais tel que sont
les gens avec moi je trouve ça très bien
ce que je suis vraiment je crois qu'avec
moi qui le cbo guerre pour moi et qu'est
ce que vous êtes en moi je suis
quelqu'un qui aime bien dire
tranquillement et bien profiter de la
vie y menant l'une à un peu mais je
crois que souvent les acteurs sont
timides pour ça qu'ils vont sur scène
vous avez du talent ça aussi le talent
je crois que c'est les gens qui pas
voulu répondre pour moi je trouve ça oui
ou non mais c'est difficile de répondre
ce que si je vous réponds d'antan n'est
pas vous allez me dire c'est de la
fausse modestie
et si je vous dis j'en ai je vais avoir
l'air d'une grosse est disons que j'ai
quelque chose sinon je crois que ce
serait parvenu à se croit pas que les
gens payent leur place pour aller voir
des gens qui n'ont rien du tout je pense
et c'est ramène toujours sert au sport
ça faisait des boxeurs il boxe moins
bien que d'autres mais ils ont ça dans
la main écrit les gens vont les voir il
faut dix ans à voir la petite étincelle
qui sait que les gens vont vouloir je
pense que je dois l'avoir puisque je
suis là quand même depuis quelques
années il vous arrive d'avoir peur peur
de quelque chose on peur oui c'est un
massoud avoir peur d'ailleurs de massy
joue au théâtre j'aurais peur pour
commencer le 4 févr oui ça me ferait
peur parce que j'ai pas joué depuis 12
ans s'éclate vraiment je ne sais pas
comment je réagirais donc quand j'en
parle je me fais peur on dit parfois que
un homme qui ne sait pas qui ne sait pas
aimer mais pas l'être humain alors
est-ce que vous avez le sens rennes ille
sens de l'amour
ah oui je crois mais je crois que c'est
200 à l'amour je les ai la haine aux
successions nation ne déteste pas
certaines personnes ou certains c'est
vraiment on est ils ont ainsi pu mal il
ya toujours des gens qui vous font des
vacheries né le to7 sans rappeler de
savoir resservir quand il faut ou sur le
moment où un peu [ __ ] politiquement
jean paul belmondo vous êtes engagé je
vous dis à moi j'ai des idées précises
c'est à dire politiquement si je fais de
la politique vous a fait en privé mais
je m'en sers pas de mon métier moi je
suis très content les acteurs qui font
de la politique qui vise des choses
définitives sur 6 ou saint aignan qui
les chante même qui les chantent parce
que moi je joue pour tous les publics
jouent pour les communistes les
royalistes et tout ce qu'on veut c'est
mon métier est ce que j'ai à faire dans
la vie je le fais moi mais je m'en sers
fanon dans mon métier ne s'est pas
influencer les gens et je pense que le
métier d'acteur est un très beau métier
qui consiste à divertir les gens et non
pas leur fils ait des idées dans la tête
alors dire c'est ça qui est bon c'est ça
qui est mauvais c'est pas notre métier
vous êtes un type bien c'est pas pour
demander à ma concierge rien à vous
reprocher ensuite tout le monde a
quelque chose à te reproche negra autre
chose grave s'il ya plusieurs choses ça
finit par exemple belmondo qu'est ce que
vous pensez de josé artur bab c'est josé
artur j'ai connu comme acteur bons
acteurs
hu s'était pas brillante le bien le dire
et maintenant il m'a dit qu'il était à
la télévision et qui faisait rage
ça marche très bien ça marche bien il
est bon très bien et a trouvé sa voie
allons trouver sa voie
oui josé artur à des signalements longer
la glace bon on se dit vous oui je sais
mieux c'est plus sérieux ya une chose
qui est tout de même importante jean
paul belmondo mon cher oui semble de
l'amitié nom déjà c'est vrai oui vous
avez quelques copains des copains de
longue date
oui ça fait vingt ans déjà il ya deux
ans c'est pas comme maria maria il y
avait renié les radios marielle
rochefort au score et il ya aussi michel
beaune et j'ai aussi dans la boxe
morisseau z kanye copains qui vingt ans
aussi est-ce que vous parlez beaucoup de
neuf dans la vie a beaucoup aimé l'art
je crois que justo les femmes ça l'est
parce que j'ai une fille j'ai une
passion de s'associer de choses
merveilleuses gens parlent beaucoup
ce qui doit me donnait d'ailleurs une
réputation d'intellectuel très marqué
c'est ça qui curieux gens voient le
monde sait que vous avez vous êtes un
homme physique
vous êtes un beau mec un beau gosse vous
aux passionnés de boxe est néanmoins
vous avez quand même la réputation de
thermique qui peut qui peut causer dans
le poste qui peut compter ses vrais il
quand même ça c'est pas on dit par de
bordeaux je ne sais pas si c'est parce
que vous avez été président du syndicat
d'acteurs sais pas si c'est parce que
vous avez quand même joué effect je vous
ai joué shakespeare
il faut pas oublier oui alors je vous ai
vu dans shakespeare c'est que c'est la
force de l'acteur on retient tous les
textes par coeur qu'ils ont leur place
comme ça dans des interviews ça serait
bien
je vais maintenant me faut pas de m
on voit le deuil est très bon les autres
les concurrents vont s'en servir l'état
remettra le dr non mais la boxe
à new york pour frasier clair non parce
que j'étais à athènes et avec omar
sharif on a loué un avion mais pour
aller à rome parce que c'était pas
télévisée et alors on l'a vu ça dans la
nuit et le matin est reparti tourner le
casque et la laverie noir pour moi c'est
ça jean paul belmondo c'est de ne pas
aller là où là bas pour voir le match et
que toute la presse disent que vous y
êtes
oui c'est ça m'a ouvert mon journal
c'était trop sur ce marché ont fait
l'histoire garden de new york
et alors je vais où je pense souvent les
persuader que j'ai été séparé et moi je
connais par contre 2 outre un chanteur
qui n'y ont pas quittés qui ont payé
leur place et pitch ne sais pas d'où
journal enfin les nommer bon alors je
suis très ennuyé parce que j'arrive en
dernier ah oui on a tout dit tiré le
mauvais numéro le 17e au numéro ses
complices alors pourquoi ils auraient du
temps je vous ai demandé de faire la
synthèse ce qu'on vous a demandé ça
m'évitera de vous poser mais sachez que
je peux non je peux vous poser question
puis je rêvais répondre autre chose
cgnews
mais par exemple ce qu'on vous a demandé
jusqu'ici grosso modo ce soit yann a été
lâché par le théâtre l'amitié les amis
qui j'ai même si j'aime pas pas les
questions classiques se connaissent et
qu'ils sont racistes
j'ai retrouvé le texte initial où
j'avais fait avec vous
c'était au moment de la sirène acteur
mort staline ou ai je demandé s'ils
étaient d'accord sur cette france que
j'ai lu quelque part il ya actuellement
deux jeunes eux premiers pas trois mais
deux seuls jeux une première en france
c'est belmondo et de long ce que vous
êtes d'accord toujours c'est à dire que
disant que c'est nous deux qui sommes là
depuis longtemps maintenant ce que ce
que je regrette et sincèrement c'est que
je pense que delon com - dont il sort
pas trop longtemps il ya beaucoup de
rôles qu'on ne pourra plus jouer et
qu'on ne voit pas vraiment un jeune ou
deux jeunes derrière
j'ai très bien peut-être suivant sortir
demain c'est ce qu'il faudrait je trouve
que ce serait une bonne chose il n'ya
pas d'après voulons les mains non mais
de il ira pas à nouveau
belmondo ou un nouveau nom parce que je
trouve ça toujours dommage de dire moi
aussi par sortir du geste un nouveau
gars ben non il ya eu un gamin démarre à
3 2
c'est un geek un belmondo oui mais il y
aura un autre derrière qui aura sa
personnalité qui sera fort et qui sera
j'avais juré de faire tout voir je vous
poser une dernière question question
encore clastiques si vous étiez
journaliste il ya une question à poser à
belmondo quelles questions vous
trouveriez bas c'est ça moi je voulais
dire si j'étais journaliste ne saurais
pas quoi lui poser comme question
sincèrement parmi le lot mais rien qui
est meilleur on sait quelle est la chose
qui vous énerve le plus dans la vie
c'est quand il ya en dehors des intérêts
je me suis jamais dit si oui quand je
rentre qu'un c'est demain ce qui met pas
posé cette question tant que je trouve
très bien
oui moi je suis très toujours très bon
sens lens a affirmé duel mois voilà bah
c'est le mode 9 et à la prochaine
je tiens à dire aux spectateurs que tout
ceci est archi